le fait est la minute nécessaire de
monsieur cyclopède l'été bel et bien
nécessaire
reprenons ensemble le texte de cette
émission d'une minute publié dans la
collection de poche points seuil et qui
a marqué l'histoire de la télévision
tout comme en son temps les raisins
verts de jean christophe averty pierre
desproges entre en scène et la pensée
que l'on n'appelait pas encore unique
allait en prendre un sérieux coup
commençons comme il nous le propose par
décrisper la berri goulaine
à condition bien entendu de ne pas la
séparer de sa compagne lapin folichonne
assurons-nous et comme il fait bien que
superman ne serait pas un peu mes textes
sur les bords bien française
l'alsacienne elle décolle pour peu qu'on
lui propose des saucisses de strasbourg
rassurant non commémorons n'importe quoi
comme par exemple la mort de jean-pierre
des morale à qui l'on doit la
démoralisation des français encore bravo
apprenons à reconnaître le châteauneuf
du pape
à ma gauche un château neuf à ma droite
le pape
essayons enfin de ne pas rire avant la
fin d' hamlet un peu de tenue je vous en
prie